okay here we are back on the internet we
were just making fun of preach should
there be 18 year term limits for the
Supreme Court yes some people have
mentioned that I would say yes because
Trump got two picks in a year and a half
Jimmy Carter never got one zero that's
yeah it's it's it's Nixon got four
Reagan got four yes look so I think I
think there's a reasonable case to be
made for it I think you want to have
judicial independence which the founders
thought could be accomplished through
having life tenure but I think they also
probably thought that over time the
people in the Supreme Court would sort
of match again over a long period of
time the ideological proclivities of the
party that was appointing them but if
you look as a stat that people don't
focus on if you go back to 1968 50 in
the last 50 50 years and if you count
the new nominee there will have been 18
people appointed to the Supreme Court do
you know how many of them were appointed
by Republican presidents 14 of the 18 so
it's over 80 including four from two
presidents who did not win the popular
vote correct so because of the genre's
liberals on the court well but but the
reason why people haven't freaked out
more than they might have is because in
you know yesteryear there were times
when a president like Gerald Ford would
appoint someone like John Paul Stevens
who ended up not being as ideologically
pure and and right-wing as some of the
people you have now that that problem
has been solved by the right in various
ways but it is interesting to see how
lopsided it has been even though
Democrats had been in office for you
know a much different percentage of the
time than the 14 to 18 would would
suggest so you know what the founders
screwed up they didn't know that we
would stop smoking so they they didn't
think they would be living in to aid
their 80s and 90s you know if we were
still a smoking country we wouldn't have
to worry about term limits we wouldn't
have a country run by people who are all
88 89 years old
so you're saying America was never
really that great they were lousy - oh
boy this is a rough day America ok
Charlie are you going to join other
principled conservatives and vote for
Democrats in the midterm I would prefer
to vote for sane rational Republicans I
just I can't find them right let me know
don't tell me you're gonna write in you
know the Pope or you know Reagan you
know that's just a chick well it would
definitely won't be the Pope no no
you're mad at them yeah you but no
you're not gonna vote Democratic you
know I'm only two sides so it's like
well okay we gotta pick a side race by
race and I do think that America needs
to have like - not crazy parties and I
do think that a principled conservatives
all abandon the Republican Party you're
gonna leave it to the you know the the
swamp lizards and the crackpots and the
trumpets but as of right now I don't see
a me any any constituency for
Republicans who are going to stand up
against Donald Trump and I do think this
election is gonna be a referendum on
constitutional what about I democracy
about the next presidential mean John
Kasich looks like he's making some moves
I mean I'm Mitt Romney if he could find
a spine consistent consistently he could
be you know do you think there will be a
challenge from the Republican classic
wing of the party yeah there will be a
challenge and it will fail because the
the party's basically become as Jonathan
was saying has become kinetic Hall tick
now if it saps
enough vote right way to elect the
Democrat when it will succeed well and
that's why it should do it was not
saying John Kasich will win the election
but if he runs as a third party
character third party candidate will be
interesting but then again I mean don't
underestimate the donald trump could be
re-elected
oh I don't yeah you know I mean never
underestimate the capacity of the
Democrats to blow this oh I'm the guy
who says he's you know anything even if
he loses the election so
not really funny but okay
Jennifer how important is the election
of women to the success of the
Democratic Party boy talk about you take
that there's day you never get a more
softball right down the middle about why
they're not no and we're gonna see I
mean we have seen these incredible
numbers for for those of you who have
been watching this women are killing
them women are killing it both in
winning run they've raised their hands
there's a great stat that comes out of
Emily's list were in the midterms last
cycle last time they had about 900 women
who had raised their hands to say they
wanted emily's list help in this cycle
40,000 women have raised their hands to
say in some way shape or form they
wanted
for an office you know with you know I
mean between extremely Daniels and I
morose [ __ ] grabbing tape and women I
think it is women who are gonna wind up
everything down this country Melania one
of the smartest analysts of the
elections empirical in the house is Dave
Wasserman works at cook Political Board
and he called this year he's already
called it the year of the angry female
college graduate and that I'll tell you
when you talk to Trump's political
advisors that is the constituency they
fear most because they already vote in
huge numbers and he's approval rating
among them is I think twenty six percent
something like that it's truly how many
voted for him in 2016 I don't know what
the college-educated women he won
White's women and he says I won women he
actually means white women I don't know
what his numbers they were actually not
so bad they were not so bad in 2016 and
now he's underwater even with white
women just white women without
college-educated so free tile has the
Trump family gone so many years in New
York City without facing major
prosecution great question I would love
to know that she gets the easy yeah my
dad
[Applause]
just write some headlines there no
because let's watch Nathan's one laugh
some more
Adam is it naive to believe that
California's wildfires could be random
or are they truly due to manmade climate
change oh that's a that's a softball
question for me they're absolutely due
to manmade climate change but but not
just that
is it not just say here's what people
don't realize what answer differently
you would have ruined you for being
here's what people don't realize is that
when natural disasters happen and people
say oh it's an act of God we really are
the ones who make the natural disaster
so destructive in the case of fires it's
because we built we're doing this on
this show coming this year it's because
we build homes so far out in the
wilderness that now we extinguish every
single fire that happens right but those
are like you know forests need a certain
amount of fire you know like small fires
everywhere clean out the dead wood when
you extinguish every fire because oh my
god now people are the suburbs have
encroached out into the forest then the
dead wood builds up and then when the
fire does come it's a real [ __ ]
and that's what we're seeing that's what
we're seeing right now I mean it's
impossible to live in California and not
realize that climate change is real and
that we live in a man-made landscape
that is crumbling under its own weight
it's really astonishing have a nice
weekend everybody
[Applause]